had coached the Los Angeles chargers
Anthony Lynn he's called into the
program how are you coach I'm doing fine
how you doing this morning
I'm doing great I'm better for chatting
with you that's good here so how did you
find out about one of your top corners
going down in a conditioning drill I
mean huh it happened right in front of
me and you know Jason's face is not
really close you know he's worked so
hard to get back on the field
you know what the agencies had in the
past and and we're just running a
conditioning test and he looks good he's
in great shaping and he's just running
and change so he goes to the ground I
probably might have a cramp but you know
I had no idea it was an Achilles and it
was just it was the emotional moments
because you know we all do our hard work
to get back and it was so bad for Jason
but you know we all loved him and and we
know that if anybody can get through
this he can't right it's just again
you've only been there just for a couple
of years and you've been around the
block the NFL block and know there's
really no such thing as being snake bit
but I just don't understand I mean right
I mean Honda Henry goes down earlier
this this year and it just seems that
these things happen to the Chargers
coach I'm wondering how do you how do
you process I think if you I told you I
think you might think he'll believe that
but if you look around the league it
happens everywhere it is happen all the
places left in and you know when I got
here I know we had a pretty bad record
and injuries and I thought last year we
took a step forward with that and I'm
still hopeful this year that we can I
know we've lost a couple guys early but
you know everybody everyone goes through
two or three of these so I don't think
you just have to does I look around the
league and sometimes I wonder these
athletes are getting bigger stronger
faster technology is better medicines
better
supplements and somehow sometimes it
seems more fragile hard I don't get that
but it is what it is it certainly isn't
but there's one thing that the Chargers
have potentially that no other
franchises can state certainly if a
Titan goes down is the possibility of
reaching out to somebody like Antonio
Gates is that of is that a feasibility
coaches which I it's possible you know
we're talking those out and Antonio is
on some interest and coming back and and
right now we're talking trying to see
what we can get done
Antony Lin Chargers head coach joining
me here on the Rich Eisen show what's it
what was it like being hooked up with
Phillip Rivers for season what you learn
about Phillip that you might not have
already known coach you know a lot of it
when you play against San Diego
you know you go through the personnel
and and you talk about the players
psyche and their skillset and you look
me any advantage of disadvantage you
know when you to the opponent but so I
knew a lot about see please send angle a
lot but being here with him you know
it's just it's everything I've heard you
know he's a he's a coach on the field
and this guy studies them no different
than I do and we share our philosophies
ideals and that that's great to have in
your quarterback because you know that
when he's on the field you know he can
get people he can help people around him
and that's a real tough feeling but you
know he has a lot of passion to it and
and I've seen the other side of that
passion what's it like when you know he
thinks that he's got a convertible
fourth in short and you send the punt
team out coach what's like that what's
that like you know we had a couple blows
last year you know I know like you know
don't let the competitive side you get
the best of you well you know I want to
take some chances on you know fourth
down below
you know it's depending on the situation
but he just has so much confidence and
himself and the people around him that
you know he just believes it was a 14-7
we actually had one hooking it over the
fort not that that would matter but I'm
just wondering just with the particular
ISM you know but you know it was like oh
we can get this and you love that about
him so you love that you don't want to
take it away because that's just a part
of his fabric and that's what makes them
special you know and uh but it's uh
there's something else Anthony Lin
Chargers head coach joining me here on
the show what do you think year to you
are gonna be better equipped for the
lack of a better phrase to handle in
real time or with extra time you've been
thinking about it from year one year two
of being an H C in the NF oh well I'll
tell you not one particular thing I just
think you know and your two you most
familiar with everything you know your
coaches your players and the schemes
that they do best and so hopefully I'm
gonna put these guys in better positions
and make plays and I'll work to the
strengths of this football team you know
there was some things lashes that I was
really trying to instill and building
his team because I believe that certain
things you have to have to want a
championship like what you know you have
to have a balanced attack you can't just
be a you know everyone say this is a
pass heavy league and all that when you
look at you know the teams that are in
the in the tournament every year and the
teams are winning the championships know
those teams are in the top five and rush
attempts you know you have to be
balanced you know in National Football
League if you just one-dimensional a
defense can take that away there's that
good so you have to be balanced but you
know sometimes you're running us out the
pass you pass this out to run but I know
last year I wanted I wanted to instill
that physical mentality and his team and
that grit and there were some times I
was a little too stubborn and that
that's going to come with time and until
that time comes you got a place at
strengthen your football team and
hopefully I can put these guys in better
position to sure to do that when you
mean stubborn Anthony
what do you mean you were too stubborn
when I would tell you we play the
devil's we played Denver in that second
game we own the one your line on gold
and we weren't at ball four times and I
roll on the one-yard line and we could
around a run action and with a score
like that it would've been an easy
touchdown but I wanted my guys to know
that they knew was right ahead
we knew we was writing it and we won our
physical there and that was a defining
moment for me and I was like you know as
the first time that's ever happened I've
ever been stopped and you know but that
was me being stubborn you know we won
that game but you know I would hate if
we had a low state game because that was
me down a little stubborn
trying to prove a point trying to still
you know football school it's a physical
contest and this you're always evolving
you're always growing but the one thing
that doesn't change about this game is
such as Akali and at the end of the day
to take this most physical wins majority
of the time so that's something that uh
as a mindset that I want us to have and
but that comes with time and it comes
with personnel well when he want to talk
about physical nature the other side of
the ball for you guys I mean you know
we've had Ingram on this show and he
just he was he wanted to talk about
nothing except hunting quarterbacks I
mean that's it I mean and and yeah Bosa
on top of it as well how does that group
rank for people that you I've seen on
the other side of the ball in your
coaching and playing career you know the
rector at the top of seeing a lot of
dynamic rushes and Madison trainee you
know and in their heyday and even in our
division right now you know you've got a
Von Miller on one side you got this new
rookie coming in who I really like and
you've got the other kid that was with
them last year that was hurt I forget
his name right now I'm Jane right you're
saying right yeah I watched him in
Missouri I mean he can go on either at
Kansas City you got forward and he's got
Houston and then Oakland you've got Mack
you know you've got urban so you have
these edge rushes everywhere and we're
not the only one but I like the two that
I asked
and that work ethic their mentality yes
stayed they want to get after the
quarterback but well I like I like the
buttons that they're unselfish too you
know they they they root for each other
and they do things to free the other guy
up to go get the second and it and
they're starting to play more run
defense no you asked impasse for us to
get down to six techniques and five
techniques and defending the run and
they would do that because it's not
selfish know that sometimes you get guys
they just want to go side quarterback
and they don't grow by descending to run
or I got no that's something that we
have to be better at this year you know
we refer to well and I realize here and
that's sometimes that's common with the
past was team it's hard to stop the
wrong we just hit the quarterback and so
we have to just find that balance but I
guys it was that a couple more minutes
left with Chargers head coach Anthony
Lin we've been knocking on your door for
a bit to get you on the show you were
supposed to be on last week but you went
to the funeral for Tony Sparano I'd love
to give you the floor and tell us so
what what that was like that that
ceremony in seeing all that your
colleagues that were there coach Toronto
you know I went to the viewing on
Thursday and the service was actually on
Friday which is a daily open so I was
been all day Thursday there with the
family and a half known that family for
a long time and 28 our longtime friends
and his son and I coached together for
four or five years and his wife Jeanette
is just the sweetest lady in the world
so you know as he's done I'm a better
man so knowing him I can tell you that
but that it was a wake-up call for a lot
of those coaches a lot of coaches there
and we all sit around and we talked and
we just we just couldn't believe that
our friend wasn't here with us anymore
but you know we as coaches sometimes we
you know work these long hours and we
have to take better care of ourselves
and we have to make sure that you know I
health comes first and not to say that
Tony didn't because Tony was on top of
his health but it still happened and so
if it could happen to him under those
circumstances and seeing some of the
best doctors are in the Mayo Clinic in
Minnesota you know could happen to any
of us though is it was it was sad but it
was a reunion there's one thing about
the NFL it is
closed paternity and you know no matter
what team you know we all come together
and we're all one so one Brotherhood and
with next to Tony town brought us all
together that Thursday and Friday and
Parcells was the HC of those two years
where you were there in Dallas with him
do you find yourself sometimes the
wonder Parcells as I'm out there every
now and then when you're now the HC in
LA he was he's one of the smartest guys
I know in this game so it's kind of hard
not to find myself doing that you know
he you never complained about his
personalities is always that good
coaches find a way to win and I believe
that regardless you know last year we
struggled with some tricky situations
but it was never excuse for me you know
we've got to find a way to win games
even when one face is not performing as
well and I just don't think there's been
anyone as good as coach Parcells and
doing that so yeah you know using some
of his information
alright that bandwagon that charges
bandwagon is getting filled up from what
people are talking about you know a
bandwagon Auto what I think but you
better win so uh you know we certainly
plan on winning we're working on it
right now you know we got a lot of work
to do a lot of good ingredients you know
we can I'm baking a cake right now and
it's not finished yet but I like what
I'm working with
coach appreciate the time let's so I'd
love to have you in studio whenever you
are up for it and free fill send up but
you know that the the the short
quarterback van that he that he takes to
work all the time maybe you can come up
together we wouldn't waste any time
because a lot of preparation going on an
advance like that so yeah yeah all those
fourth and seven plays he wants to drive
up thanks to the call you got as Anthony
Lynn how about that the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience